in this video we'll be talking about
Frederick's itaa so Frederick aaia is a
rare genetic disorder which is a
progressive neurological disorder
affecting heart and the nervous system
so in this case brain and the heart is
the most affected tissue other than that
there is difficulty with balance and
coordination which is known as aaia
muscle weakness and disartria that means
speech related problems this particular
disease was described by Nicholas
fedick several years ago so let us
quickly have some highlights about this
disease before we delve into the details
when it comes to epidemiology the
incidence rate is 3 to 4 per 100,000
individual and the onset of symptoms is
from Early Childhood or adolescence and
males are somehow more prone to develop
Frederick's aaia compared to the females
when it comes to iology this has a
autosomal recessive inheritance trait
and the genetic cause of Frederick aaia
is trinucleotide repeat expansion GAA
repeat in the DNA of the fraxin gene
located in chromosome 9 is repeated more
than usual and that is the cause of
Frederick's Ataxia and the ultimate
consequence of that mutation which lead
to an repeat expansion is a decrease in
fraxin protein fraxin is useful for
mitochondrial functioning so in absence
of fraxin mitochondrial dysfunction is
predominant and when there is
disregulation of mitochondrial
metabolism there is increased oxidative
stress which lead to basically damage of
energy demanding cells such as neuron
and cardiomyocytes complications
involved cardiomyopathy and most of the
cases cardiomyopathy is the leading
cause of death prognosis is not that
well 10 to 15 years after symptoms onset
one one might find find out they have
fedix ATT AIA and also the individual
might require a
wheelchair anyway better prognosis is
required for this disease but it's
important to note that the life
expectancy is reduced due to Frederick's
adaia when it comes to clinical features
there is Progressive aaia there is gate
instability there is limb incoordination
disartria heart and Tremor heart
problems and tremors are pretty common
in fredia
ocular abnormalities like nagas and
dysphasia that means difficulty in
swallowing is also common sometimes
alongside these primary features there
could be uh non-motor manifestations
there could be cognitive impairment
there could be pyretic problems and
there could be peripheral neuropathy but
the most important complication is the
cardiomyopathy and that lead to the
death of the patients genetic cause of
the federic attack involves the
chromosome 9 in a chromosome 9 there's a
gene known as fraxin fraxin Gene leads
to the fraxin protein production which
is crucial for mitochondrial homeostasis
or mitochondrial functioning fraxin is
differentially expressed in different
tissues it is highly enriched in
metabolically active tissues like neuron
heart and pancreas and it is important
for the functionality of each of these
tissues in a moment it would be clear
fraxin Gene has several GAA TR
nucleotide repeats within it a normal
level is basically something around 7 to
35 repeats if the repeat number is more
than 100 then it's a pathological
situation and that lead to a mutation in
this Gene which would reduce the protein
production now in absence of fraxin or
reduced fraxin the mitochondrial
functioning is abrogated which is
detrimental for cells like neuron heart
Etc because if we zoom into the
mitochondria we would see there are
electron transport chain and the
component of the electron transport
chain for example nadh dehydrogenase
would actually use the iron sulfur
clusters these iron sulfur clusters are
actually used to relay neuron relay
electrons
from U the from basically nadh to
ultimately CQ and this kind of flow of
electron V iron sulfur cluster is
crucial for the proper functioning of
the electron transport chain
in absence of fraxin or reduced fraxin
the iron could not be incorporated into
this iron sulfur cluster that leads to a
problem so obviously this would abrogate
the uh ATP production uh uh in the
mitochondria so ATP production would be
reduced mitochondrial output would be
reduced which is detrimental for the
cells which are metabolically active
like neuron so obviously feras cannot be
incorporated in the iron sulfur cluster
instead feras helps in the oxidation of
the oxygen and Lead which lead to oxygen
radicals so increased level of Ross can
damage proteins membrane lipids and that
would have a detrimental consequences
altogether for a cell also there could
be DNA damage associated with Ross when
it comes to neurological complications
there are several locations in the body
which are affected but most prevalently
the affected regions are the corticos
spinal tract the dorsal root ganglion
and the dent nucleus in the
cerebelum other complications include
cardiac complications that means
cardiomyopathy the cardiac muscle cells
are highly uh dependent on mitochondrial
function because they require energy all
the time to pump the heart so if there
is a mitochondrial dysfunction there
would be cardiac arhythmia and several
other cardiac complications which are
the prevalent cause of death pancreatic
cells are also very active and the
secrete stuffff such as insulin
so insulin production would be decreased
if the pancreatic cells pancreatic beta
cells are not able to have enough amount
of ATP that might lead to or enhance the
chance of getting a
diabetes so let's talk about the mode of
inheritance as we mentioned earlier the
mode of inheritance is autosomal
recessive that means 1/4 is the chance
that the Next Generation would be
affected when it comes to diagnosis gate
examination examination of the family
pedigree would be useful but the key way
of detection is by genetic testing by
looking at these TR nucleotide repeat
expansion within the fraxin gene so
let's talk about the treatment options
there are no definite cure for this
Frederick's attaka but okay Physical
Therapy speech therapy genetic
counseling and supportive medication
could make the life of the patient a
little bit better so I hope this video
was useful if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe see you in next
video